listen you know i understand now this  movement this is why people in the  manosphere say you're trying to be like  men this is it's very masculine it is  i'm sorry it's very mad people gonna say  oh i'm so upset about this it's  masculine to be showing your underarm  hair like that it is to be having leg  hit that's not  it's not a feminine trait  it's not  and i am loving the opinion and i know  this won't be popular to some the modern  feminist movement but i am of the  opinion that women  should take pride in their appearance  and i like a groomed woman  i'm not saying that you gotta listen i  go get my nails done every two weeks i  don't always put polish sometimes it's  just about grooming  i get a facial and people say oh you're  doing that for other people i'm not if  you if i in fact  i'm not